Here are Greg and Lauren and they both have a problem, or a stressful event.
Their shoes are untied. Greg thinks about strategies he can use to change this
situation to reduce the stress. He could buy elastic shoes so he never has to
tie his shoes again, he could tape his shoes so that they won't come untied. Or
he could tie his shoe. These are ways in which he could change his situation to
reduce the stress of having an untied shoe. Here Greg focused on his problem
and changed his situation. This is called, problem-focused coping and it
involves looking at the situation and changing the situation that caused the
stress. Lauren on the other hand, had a different way with coping with this
some what trivial event.